*roulement de tambour*
Alors on veut des révélations ?
On veut des scoop
On veut des “doss“ comme on dit
Sur le Squeezie
EEH BEIN VOUS ALLEZ ÊTRE SERVI PUTAAIIN
Les amis, à chaque fois j'ai l'impression que j'ai pas d'autres anecdotes à raconter,
et à chaque fois en fait, les jours passent, les nuits passent,
les douches passent, parce que oui, les douches sont un moment qui stimule ta créativité
et HOP j'ai les souvenirs qui remontent gros
et à chaque fois, c'est pas des trucs qui me mettent en valeur du tout !
C'est génial !
J'ai étais un boulet pendant des années EHEH
Je le suis encore mais je m'en rendrai compte que dans  8-9 ans
et je vous racontrais des trucs que j'ai fait maintenant, dans 8-9 ans
C'est chiant cette phrase
Je gagne du temps, parce que que je profite de cette dernière seconde,
où vous n'êtes pas au courant de certaines choses
Euh ... et ...
Voilà...
Allez je vous raconte !
Tout commence, quand j'avais 11 ans.
J'habitais dans la banlieue Parisienne
Du nom d'Anthony
Un endroit très ghetto,
C'est faux ! Entièrement faux ! La plupart des gens ont des maisons, les gens vivent très très bien
Tout allait bien pour moi puisque je n'étais pas encore très addict aux jeux vidéo,
je jouais de manière raisonnable, puis je sortais m'amuser avec mes amis
Des fois, j'allais à la piscine municipale
OUUH
Même si j'avais failli me noyer là
Je vous avais raconté cette anecdote dans une autre vidéo,
C'est pas grave, le Lulu il continue de pratiquer ses petites longueurs à la piscine
ça lui fait du bien et il se sent un petit peu Aquaman.
Ce jour là, on était en juin
Grand soleil dans le ciel, je me dis, ça y est c'est mon jour. Aujourd'hui je vais nager plus vite qu'un poisson.
J'arrive à la piscine : je paie ma petite place je vais me changer là c'est le moment chiant, tu mets le bonnet de bain qui a la pire texture du
monde les mecs ils avaient un bonnet de bain en toile moi j'avais celui en
plastique qui te tire les veuch (cheveux) quand tu le mets,  le pire bonnet frère je suis sûr que ça là c'est à cause de ce bonnet à
l'époque il m'en a arraché des cheveux mec bon bref je sors du vestiaire je marche en direction
de la piscine je passe fameux bain pour pieds.
ignoble dans lequel il y a toutes les maladies du monde, mec! Y a la tuberculose là dedans comme la plupart des gens au lieu de
marcher dedans je marche sur le rebord pour le contourner et en arrivant j'ai une petite tradition souvent et vous savez à la piscine municipale y a
souvent le
bassin aux dimensions olympiques pour faire des longueurs et tout quand t'es un beau gosse et il y a le petit bassin c'est pour les gens un peu enfant
où les gens qui ont un retard mental comme moi et ce bassin là il a un avantage c'est que l'eau est plus chaude que
dans l'autre bassin alors à chaque fois j'avais pour habitude de faire un petit tour dans ce petit bassin avant d'aller dans le grand bain
dans le petit bassin et mais tous les mecs comme moi qui voulais pas affronter la fraîcheur du grand bassin et du coup il était
tous temps blindé de monde ce bassin mec et là j'arrive
miracle il y a
personne les gens sont autour du bassin, mais ne sont pas dedans. Je me dis putain j'ai le petit bassin pour moi tout seul! Ça
y est c'est plus beau jour de ma vie! je me sens un petit peu comme Bill Gates, comme si j'avais mon jacuzzi privé.
vous sentez la douille arriver. je tape le plus beau sprint de ma vie en direction du bassin. Je
fait mon plus beau saut vers le petit bassin. j'atterri dans l'eau j'ai l'impression d'être le roi du monde et quand je remonte à la surface
les emmerdes commencent. Y a un mec dans l'eau en face de moi qui me regarde un peu bizarre, alors je comprends pas je me
me dis merde. Est-ce que mon saut était tellement stylé et que je l'ai fait complexé. je sais pas putain j'avais de l'égo
déjà à l'époque
et là je vois que dans sa main il a un instrument bizarre que je serai pas identifié mais j'ai jamais vu un mec à
la piscine avec sas est ni une frite ni un harpon, ni un jet ski alors c'est quoi? Et parallèlement à ce que j'observe
j'entends des rires tout autour de la piscine. Je comprends pas mais est ce que j'ai perdu mon short de bain dans le feu de l'action et
je réalise que ce qu'il a dans la main c'est un aspirateur
aquatique et qu'il était en train d'aspirer la merde qu'un enfant avait fait dix minutes avant que je plonge dans l'eau c'est beau
Vous vous doutez bien étant donné qu'il était vraiment collé à moi le mec j'avais vraiment sauté sur la merde
j'étais ravie je sors de l'eau j'ai très très long cette fois ci en marchant dans le patient il ya la tuberculose broca ou nettoyer
les
les résidus s'il y en a jamais de kaka sur mes pieds je retourne aux vestiaires la meuf de l'accueil vois je retourne aux vestiaires
et média sas mal pas si ça va tout va bien laisser moi je veut devenir
invisible à l'heure actuelle vous comprenez ça je veux plus personne ne me parle pendant deux semaines je veux mourir je suis rentré chez moi
humilié ma dignité est resté dans le bassin tout comme la merde de ce jeune garçon si toi carrière cette vidéo soit souvenir d'avoir chier
dans le petit bassin de la piscine municipale de anthony beh va te faire fourte ok j'ai avec mes coupes manor dix ans après ses bons
voilà à la première révélation est faite j'ai sauté dans un bassin rempli de kaka on peut passer à autre chose c'est bon
merci deuxième anecdote ça s'est passé quand j'étais au lycée en seconde
j'étais dans un centre commercial qui s'appelle okabe qui situe au kremlin bicêtre
pareil pas très loin d'ailleurs de anthony les détails de merde mais il faut que je gagne du temps sur la vidéo encore une fois
là vous n'êtes pas au courant de ce qui va suivre donc ma dignité et encore un peu présent j'avais des potes qui devait me
rejoindre là-bas et je sais pas pourquoi j'ai une grosse idées de gags nul à chier mais vraiment un gag nul vraiment genre le gag
du cafard en plastique à côté c'est énorme je vais un supermarché qui avait dans un centre commercial
et je me dis putain avant que mes potes arrive je vais acheter une teinture et je vais me la faire et comme ça quand
ils arriveront j'aurai les cheveux noirs et ils comprendront pas
trop drôle
alors je vais au supermarché je veux rayon peinture y en a des milliards des milliards mais que je savais pas qu'il y avait autant
de marques il faisait des teintures je prends une teinture et je vois en petit son côté la boîte qu'il ya marqué
attention tu veux acheter une teinture et on te dis attention
bizarre tester la teinture avant de l'appliquer sur votre cuir chevelu à pourvoir si j'aime la couleur écru sûr de bien vouloir prendre celle ci
est pas une haute ou mettez un peu de produit sur une toute petite partie de votre peau pour voir si elle ne réagit pas
mal pendant les 24 prochaines heures
c'est vrai que des gens sont allergiques aux teintures mais pas moi
Je me dirige alors avec matin sur toute neuve dans les toilettes du centre commercial
on en est là on en est là sur le mec va au bout de son bail
il se dit pas un moment peut-être que c'est une idée de merde je mets ma tête sous l'eau en plus le lavabo était petit
donc j'avais genre la tête coincée entre le robinet et l'évier c'est un enfer
j'applique la teinture je rince je suis content je sors des toilettes avec les cheveux noirs mes potes étaient déjà arrivés le gag
marche très peu ils font vraiment un pas de plus et a les cheveux noirs
on va manger mais laird la suite est bien plus triste le soir je me couche et mon crâne me gratte
énormément je me gratte une grade je me gratte puis je me dis qu'on soit grade généralement faut pas trop de gratter ça empire le
truc tu vois un peu comme un bouton de moustiques alors j'arrête de gratter je dors très mal très très mal le matin je me
lève je me regarde dans le miroir et la mecque je fais une découverte exceptionnelle c'était la taille de mon crâne
avait triplé de volume avec ma tête c'était une
montgolfière mon pote je ressemblais un alien de marsatac frère j'ai vu ma mère ma mère a explosé de rire moi j'étais en pleurs je
me disais mais c'est grave ça se trouve la tête va vraiment explosé quoi je suis pas allé à l'hôpital je me suis dit bon
on voit ça va passer c'est une petite allergies rien de grave putain y'a pas quelqu'un autour de moi qui m'a dit peut-être ce match
chez le médecin on sait jamais le surlendemain je me réveille nouvelles surprises il y avait l'équivalent de cette bouteille d'eau en liquide dans mon
front
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'odem j'avais une poche mecs dans mon front de vraiment star matelas hall truc je décide alors d'aller aux urgences
parce que là c'est chaud quoi à monsieur m'accueille il me dit ah vous a fait une allergie à une teinture vous je dis oui
il me dit bon je m'appuie sur votre front pour voir si le thème est vraiment énorme
en suisse il est vraiment énorme il peut peut-être se prolonger dans votre coup et ça va appuyer sur vos voies respiratoires vous allez mourir
oui baba sy a pu voir sur frau mec mais moi découvrir dans le fond va si je veux pas mourir le mec mais sa
meilleure force dans son doigt pour appuyer sur mon front son doigt s'enfonce dans mon front
on ne voit plus son doigt et un certain son doigt il me dit bon c'est rien vous en faites pas allez bonne nuit
mais deux mois un truc pour que ça dégonfle pour je me sente mise au projet de complexe et pour ce genre de ma dépression
je sais pas je rentre comme ça tranquillement sur mon trottoir je marche en direction de la maison je me dis tout ça ne sera
bientôt qu'un mauvais souvenir au pire c'est pas grave ça reste entre moi et ma mère mais personne du lycée n'était au courant mon honneur
est sauf et sur le trottoir d'en face un mec leurs gardes
il me reconnaît il explose de rire et continue son chemin
autant vous dire que le lendemain je n'ai pas passé un bon lot et du tout pensé wow 4
à partir de ce jour je n'ai plus jamais oser me teindre les cheveux
oui ses cheveux sont
très les amis maintenant trêve de plaisanterie nous passons à la dernière anecdote qui est celle où j'ai le plus de regrets ou j'ai merdé
comme jamais ma mère m'a envoyé chaque année en colonie elle m'avait envoyé trois ou quatre années de suite dans la même colonie qui était
une colonie de cheval savait que j'adorais les animaux du coup j'étais tout content jeux et des chevaux j'ai caressé suite du cheval jetées au
vent ça dure entre une et trois semaines une colonie vous savez très bien que certains soirs quoi on fait le mur
bah oui on sort en cachette de la chambre en faisant attention
aurons-nous des animateurs pour pas qu'ils nous prennent la main dans le sac qu'on soit puni ce soir là c'était le dernier soir de la
colonie et on avait décidé avec mes potes d'aller dans le dortoir des filles
le problème c'est que dans ce centre équestre le dortoir des filles se trouvaient à
l'opposé du dortoir des hommes on avait un pote qui est en creux sur une fille mais ça je le savais pas alors
et c'était le dernier soir il n'avait pas osé franchir le pas et il était trop deg et nous en tant que bons potes on
lui a dit mec ce soit on va atteindre le dortoir des filles et tu vas dormir avec no et
noémie et dans la meuf sûr qu'il avait un creux jamais entendu blais compris alors on sort de la chambre un modérateur passe devant nous
il ne nous voit pas on traverse le couloir ont fini par sortir du bâtiment et là on se retrouve en
extérieur le problème c'est qu'à l'extérieur se trouvait sur quasiment tous les murs des spots
automatique qui avait une zone de détection très très large si un spot s'allume ça veut dire que quelqu'un est passé devant c'est à dire
que les animateurs vont venir vers le spot est fouillé dans les environs et se passer le mot en gros on est mort c'est un
spot se détecte ok vous comprenez ça alors on s'avance discrètement de bus sont enduits son chien spot on ne peut pas à passer devant
parce que sinon on passe devant le bureau de la direction d'enquêté avait des animateurs qui devait leur café leur clope la rai buvait pas
des clopes et les fumées mais romain compris du coup on est obligé de faire un détour est de passer par
l'intérieur de l'enclos des chevaux en pleine nuit alors on passe dans cet enclos pour esquiver le bot mon pote marges dans une merde on
se retient de rire parce que vous savez c'est
horrible situation où on a envie d'exploser de rire mais tu sais que c'est explose de rire tu es mort mais du coup tu es
encore plus envie d'exploser de rire
dans le couloir qui mène pour trottoirs des filles
non oui on arrive nouvel apport du dortoir
on rentre l'une des filles dit putain ça plus d'un coup quelqu'un 1 pt non non c'est juste nous kiev
traverser les enclos des chevaux et là arnaud mon ami va dans le lit de noémie et   je sais pas ce qui me prend je vais
dans le lit de noélie avec lui
Pourquoi ? mais moi j'étais innocent j'avais 11 ans moi j'avais pas de pensées un peu
perverses ou je sais pas quoi pour moi les hommes et les femmes ne faisaient pas l'amour ils pouvaient cohabiter
en toute liberté sans jamais avoir d attirance les uns pour les autres le sexe ça n'existait pas
là vous vous dites bon et t'abuses mais au pire ça les a pas empêché de discuter de s'embrasser ah mais non attendez
je me glisse entre arnaud et Noémie de manière à vraiment niquer toutes les chances d'arnaud d'avoir un quelconque contact physique avec noemi
avec noemie on parle, on parle
arnaud des fois il arrive à s'incruster 5- 6 fois dans la conversation et on parle avec noemie et Arnaud me met des petits coups de coude
un peu comme ça de plus en plus fort au début les j'ai mes dates
du coup un peu mieux comme ça je comprends pas pourquoi il fait ça et je lui dis mais arnaud pourquoi tu me les coups
de coude le pire ami
possible du coup noémie elle comprend regard dont il a envie de s'approcher d'elle et qui c'est pour ça qu'il met des coups de coude
noémie à langueux la renommée arnaud pourquoi tu mets des coups de coude à l'uqat est malade
je fini par sortir du lit il passe trois minutes dans l'eau avant de se faire exclure du lit par noémie qui était trop fatiguée
parce qu'on a parlé pendant une heure et demie et la renommée passe un savon je croyais qu'on était potes ce que tu as fait
c'est abusé à cause de toi j'ai pas pu l'embrasser et je la reverrai plus après deux jours et
ça je trouve mais qui s'était marié aujourd'hui si j'avais pas fait ça ça se trouve c'était le début d'une grande histoire
arnaud vraiment désolé d'avoir nique et honfleur
j'espère qu'aujourd'hui tu pense plus à elle que c'est de l'histoire ancienne et vraiment je m'excuse
j'aurais dû comprendre ce qui se passait entre toi elle sentir cette petite
électricité et vous laisser les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu et que vous ne m'en voulez pas je
sais qu'il ya tous les mecs qui ont vu la vidéo on le somme contre moi
on n'a pas envie que ça nous arrive à nous ce que j'ai fait arnaud j'étais jeune innocente je me rendais pas compte de ce
que je faisais vraiment mais je m'en veux si vous
saviez comme je m'en suis voulu qu alice dona après quand j'ai compris ce que j'avais fait à cet homme mais c'était pas mais la
vue du ciel vous a plu j'espère vous aimerez quand même
mais vidéo après avoir appris que j'ai sauté dans une piscine remplie de cacau que j'ai une tête mon bol fier ou que j'ai empêché
un pote de pécho écoutez moi je vis plutôt bien malgré toutes ces erreurs c'est un peu trop d'impact je me porte bien
bon voilà n'hésitez pas à me dire d'aller grand test vous avait gaffé avec un pote qui avait un crush sur une meuf ça peut
être drôle c'est trop drôle ces histoires là c'est horrible et c'est très drôle à la fois vous fais plein de bisous
j'espère que ça vous a plu j'ai encore deux autres anecdotes pour une future vidéo anecdotes décidément je n'arrête pas d'en avoir
bon c'est incroyable et jeudi avant une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien au revoir
Outro <3 Bye Bixcrow ^^' Et d'autres pesonnes. PEACE!!!